there's a wild video that has been
making the rounds all over the internet
people are freaking out because there is
a video of people shopping in a walmart
metaverse experience what yes there is a
video that we are going to show here in
a second that has people putting on
virtual reality in the metaverse
shopping at walmart why would you want
to do that well here's what walmart
thinks that you should do great looks
like you need a good wine pairing take a
look to your right
pre-selected
your age has already been pre-verified
through your profile so no need to wait
for an id check just place the item in
your cart whenever you're ready you
can't throw wine like that
yeah most expensive bottles and then you
see right here you just kind of morph
yeah where did where did they just wait
just wait
like in the elevator kind of and then
you're gonna get dropped off in a
different section i'm getting a
notification from your connected
smartphone
you're free
should we put this one back
all right pause it first of all nobody
wants to shop in the metaverse this is
absolutely absurd but an important part
this video is actually not from now it's
from 2017. this is an old video that is
going around the internet today the
reason why that's important is because
nobody knows the difference between what
they were saying was gonna happen in
2017 and 2018 2019 2020 21 now into
2022. they still think this is what the
metaverse is going to look like ain't
nobody going to be shopping at the
grocery store in the metaverse why
because nobody likes to go to the
grocery store anyways john joe me we
don't like going to the grocery store we
order online you know how we order
online we click a couple of buttons and
we run off to the next thing we got to
do it's about efficiency it's not about
how can you morph me from one part of
the store to the other i don't need to
see the ability to turn around and
understand where next i got to go to buy
beer or to get any other groceries the
whole point of buying things online is
to be quick fast and everyone leave me
to hell alone i don't want to be
followed around by a holographic robot
that yells at me and says maybe you
should put the milk back hey lady maybe
you should leave me alone or let me buy
whatever the hell i want to buy that's
what i think about buying stuff in the
metaverse what do you two geniuses think
i thought they were supposed to make it
easier they were going in elevators they
were doing that it took a lot of time
just show me the products let me pick
and deliver to the house that seems like
the easiest solution which we already
have so i'm not sure why that's
necessary john i don't need a virtual
assistant to help me pick out my
groceries i don't need someone to tell
me to put the milk back if i want to get
two gallons of milk just for fun i will
it seems kind of redundant shopping
online is very easy right now uh
e-commerce so
i do think it raises to your point
though like no one really knows what any
of this stuff is like if you ask someone
what the metaverse is or what web 3 is
or what any of this stuff is you has
five people get five different answers
we should start which is both a good
thing and a bad thing for them i think
we should start the very first web3
metaverse grocery store that you can
come in and buy nft food
it's like uh it's like you remember that
app that was on the iphone like years
ago that was like i think it literally
was called i'm rich and it was like you
buy it it was like ten thousand dollars
and it was just an app on your phone it
literally did nothing it was just a dot
basically and it showed i'm rich and
like some of these people have no idea
what any of this stuff i mean that's
pretty good yeah that is i mean they
sold some of them i'm sure yeah of
course all right next thing i want to
just point out here very quickly if we
can pull up the video again we don't
necessarily have to play it is if you
look at this the reason why this isn't
going to work is because all you're
doing is you're taking something that
already exists in the shopping
experience like physically looking at
the uh store and also online shopping
and you're trying to bring it into the
metaverse that's not how new technology
actually disrupts or is innovative what
you have to do is we have to find the
things that are digitally native or
metaverse native what is the thing that
now you can do that you previously
couldn't do that's where stuff like
virtual reality and the metaverse is
going to end up finding kind of product
market fit it's not in oh guess what now
you don't have to walk in the store oh
now you don't have to order online you
can go do it in the metaverse like
nobody gives a [ __ ] right instead it's
what is the new thing that is unlocked
just like when the iphone came out it
had gps now all of a sudden you could
actually get uber because everybody had
an iphone that was a driver and also
that was a writer bam put you together
and we got uber what did this unlock as
new functionality that's where the true
value is going to be not in walmart
trying to get us to go and buy our
virtual groceries which just disappeared
into a grave uh there's going to be no
way for us to actually get this to mass
adoption because guess what our mom
isn't going to use this stuff neither is
any of your moms or dads and neither are
we which means this is d-o-a walmart
metaverse shopping dead on arrival